con un estilo fresco y la promesa de
hacer una política distinta nayib bukele
asumió Hace cuatro años la presidencia
de El Salvador
ustedes decidirán cómo quieren ser
gobernados porque hoy tendremos Un
gobierno del pueblo para el pueblo
bukele Ha logrado captar la atención de
la comunidad internacional por sus
controversiales políticas y decisiones
calificadas como autoritarias una de
ellas se registró el 9 de febrero de
2020 cuando el mandatario tomó junto con
el ejército la asamblea legislativa tras
la negativa de los diputados para
aprobar la financiación de su plan de
seguridad hasta que finalmente lo
consiguió el plan de control territorial
es la estrategia insignia del mandatario
para acabar con las pandillas del país
que controlaban el 80% del territorio y
para 2015 llevó a El Salvador a tener la
tasa de homicidios más alta del mundo
queda aprobado el proyecto lo que hizo
que el 27 de marzo de 2022 El Congreso
aprobara por pedido de bukele un régimen
de excepción vigente hasta la fecha como
respuesta a una escalada de violencia
que en un solo día dejó 62 muertos la
medida permite capturas sin orden
judicial e incluso a aquellos que tengan
tatuajes además el presidente inauguró
una mega cárcel con capacidad para
albergar cerca de 40.000 detenidos el
gobierno difunde con orgullo imágenes de
los presos descalzos Encadenados y
ordenados perfectamente
según bukele hasta el 10 de mayo el país
completó 365 días no continuos sin
homicidios medidas que cuentan con más
del 90% de la aprobación Popular según
encuestas pero con el rechazo de la
comunidad internacional la gente le está
diciendo al gobierno aquí estamos y no
estamos de acuerdo en ciertas políticas
que usted está haciendo anteriormente
era difícil sobrevivir
a uno no sabía si volvía a llegar a
regresar a la casa otra vez la
popularidad de bukele quedaría
demostrada en las urnas en 2024 tras
anunciar su intención de lanzarse por
reelección a pesar de ser
inconstitucional Según la ley
salvadoreña